As we head into the final days of this presidential race, consider this story. Matt Futterman was running for student government in Mamaroneck High School in New York in 1985. And he ran a campaign that changed electoral politics in the school, at least for a while. Here's the way the race lined up.
随着总统大选进入最后几天，请听听这个故事。1985年，马特·福特曼正在纽约马马罗内克高中竞选学生会职务。他发起的一场竞选活动至少在一段时间内改变了学校的选举政治。当时竞选形势是这样的。
My opponent was a guy named [? Dave Levy, ?] who was a year older than I. He was going to be a senior, and he was running for this position. So you had to figure he was going to win that class. I was going to win my class. And then it was up to the freshmen who were going to decide the election.
我的对手是一个叫[戴夫·列维]的家伙，他比我大一岁。他那时即将升入高三，正在竞选这个职位。所以你肯定觉得他会赢得那一届的选票。我会赢得我那一届的选票。剩下的就是大一新生，他们将决定选举结果。
And it was not looking good for Matt with those key swing voters, the tough-to-please freshmen. And it came to the final days before the election, just as we are now, with this presidential race. And Matt turned to his best friend's brother, Bennett, for advice. And Bennett came up with this campaign slogan that turned the race around. Here's Bennett.
马特在这些关键摇摆选民——那些难以取悦的大一新生身上——的情况不太妙。就像我们现在的总统大选一样，距离选举只剩下最后几天了。马特向他好朋友的哥哥本内特寻求建议。本内特想出了一条扭转竞选局势的口号。请听本内特怎么说。
"Vote for Matt. He is good. He'll give you wood." Essentially, Matt would walk around Mamaroneck Public High School with an armful of various types of wood, twigs and sticks and lumber and such. And anybody who wanted wood would get a free sample of wood.
“投马特一票。他很棒。他会给你木头。”基本上，马特会抱着各种木头、树枝、棍子和木材之类的东西，在马马罗内克公立高中走来走去。任何想要木头的人都会得到一份免费的木头样本。
Then Bennett had another idea. They could make a TV commercial. That's right, a TV commercial. Nobody had ever done a political TV ad in a high school race, at their school anyway. The school had TVs in every room. The school's morning announcements were done on these television monitors. They could play their ad during the morning announcements.
然后本内特又有了一个主意。他们可以拍一个电视广告。没错，一个电视广告。在高中竞选中，至少在他们学校，从来没有人做过政治电视广告。学校每个教室都有电视。学校的晨间广播是通过这些电视监视器完成的。他们可以在晨间广播期间播放他们的广告。
The next day, I met Ben at the beginning of lunch. And we went to the video room. And he signed out the cameras and tripod.
第二天，我在午餐开始时见到了本。我们去了录像室。他签借了摄像机和三脚架。
And we went out back to the parking lot. And I think he had brought some logs for me to hold. And the whole thing took about 15 minutes to film.
我们走到后面的停车场。我想他带了一些木头让我拿着。整个拍摄过程只用了大约15分钟。
I'm standing there with wood. The shot opens. I'm there. I say, "Hi. I'm Matt Futterman. I'm running for Corresponding Secretary of the Executive Board."
我站在那里拿着木头。镜头打开。我在那儿。我说：“嗨。我是马特·福特曼。我正在竞选执行委员会的通讯秘书。”
I think maybe Matt said, "Vote for me. I am good. I'll give you wood."
我想马特可能说了：“投我一票。我很棒。我会给你木头。”
Bennett has his arm around me. He's got a microphone in his hand. He pulls it back to his mouth. He looks very seriously into the camera, and he says--
本内特把手搭在我的肩膀上。他手里拿着一个麦克风。他把它拉回到嘴边。他非常严肃地看向镜头，然后他说——
I said, "What do you mean? You're going to give it away for free?" He says, "That's right, Bennett, absolutely for free. You want birch, I got birch. You want oak, I got oak. You want pine, you want twigs--"
我说：“你什么意思？你要免费送出去吗？”他说：“没错，本内特，完全免费。你想要桦木，我有桦木。你想要橡木，我有橡木。你想要松木，你想要树枝——”
"Oak, beech, maple, magnolia, linden."
“橡木、山毛榉、枫木、木兰、椴木。”
"You want sticks, you want two-by-fours, I got it for you."
“你想要棍子，你想要二乘四的木料，我都有。”
And Bennett looks very seriously into the camera and holds up a log and says, "redwood."
然后本内特非常严肃地看向镜头，举起一根原木说：“红杉。”
Let me just ask you to describe-- just choose one word and describe-- OK, this ad airs for the first time during the morning announcements. Describe in one word the reaction from the school.
让我请你描述一下——只用一个词描述——好的，这个广告第一次在晨间广播时播出。用一个词描述学校的反应。
It would have to be fanaticism. And like pigeons to the bread-bearer, he was just swarmed upon by students from every grade wanting a piece of wood.
那肯定就是狂热。就像鸽子涌向喂食者一样，他被各个年级的学生团团围住，都想要一块木头。
People were coming up for seconds, for thirds.
人们跑回来要第二份，第三份。
It was just like a Hail Mary touchdown.
这就像是一个绝地求生的达阵得分。
And before I know it, I'm looking down in the bag. And I'm very quickly running out of wood. And I'm thinking, "I got to get some more wood."
还没等我反应过来，我低头看包里。木头很快就要用完了。我在想，“我得再弄点木头来。”
It got to the point where he was giving away so much wood, there was such a demand to give away the wood, that he had to stop giving it away to seniors, because they didn't have the right to vote in school-wide elections.
后来到了这样的地步，他送出了太多的木头，以至于发放木头的需求太大，他不得不停止向高三学生发放，因为他们没有校级选举的投票权。
Did you have to modify the ad with a little, at the end, "Seniors not apply."
你是否不得不在广告最后加了一句，“高三学生不适用。”
I believe the ad played one time.
我相信那个广告只播了一次。
One time was enough, though. Come election day, Matt easily swept into office. And the next year, because of Matt's commercial, the age of televised politics hit Mamaroneck High full-force. Nearly all the candidates had TV ads.
不过一次就够了。选举日那天，马特轻松当选。第二年，因为马特的商业广告，电视政治时代全面冲击了马马罗内克高中。几乎所有的候选人都制作了电视广告。
And interestingly, nearly all of them were dreadfully dull. They went on TV, and they droned on about their qualifications and what they wanted to do for the school. It's as if they missed what it was that made Matt's ad so effective. Here's Bennett.
有趣的是，他们几乎都极其乏味。他们上电视，喋喋不休地谈论他们的资格以及他们想为学校做些什么。就好像他们错过了马特广告之所以有效的原因。请听本内特怎么说。
It appealed directly to what was most important to the students. And what was most important was not the traditionally defined offices and duties of an elected official. People did not care about the prom and about the track team's uniforms. What they cared about was being represented. And this sense of absurdity--
它直接诉诸于对学生最重要的东西。而最重要的不是民选官员传统定义的办公室和职责。人们不在乎舞会和田径队的队服。他们在乎的是被代表。以及这种荒谬感——
The sense of absurdity in the ad.
广告中的那种荒谬感。
--the sense of absurdity that Matt was willing to express in the ads does represent who they were.
——马特愿意在广告中表达的那种荒谬感，代表了他们自己。
Which brings us to the current election. While it's true that we want candidates with whom we agree, more or less, on at least some of the so-called issues, I think we also want, or I want anyway-- and I don't think I'm alone in this-- some moment of spontaneity, of human joy, some "I'll give you wood" moment. It would make me feel like I could trust these guys.
这就带我们回到了当前的选举。虽然我们确实希望有候选人，在所谓的某些议题上，我们多多少少能与他们达成一致，但我认为我们也想要，或者至少我想要——我想我并不孤单——一些自发性、人性乐趣的时刻，一些“我会给你木头”的时刻。这会让我觉得我能信任这些人。
The candidates know this, too. At this point in the evolution of focus-grouped, to poll-driven politics, they have absolutely learned that what we want is some moment that is not focus-grouped and poll-driven. So they go onto David Letterman. They go onto Jay Leno. They tell their little jokes. They try to charm, all to try to get outside the sound bites.
候选人也知道这一点。在如今这种焦点小组和民调驱动的政治演变阶段，他们绝对学到了我们想要的是那些没有经过焦点小组测试和民调驱动的时刻。所以他们去大卫·莱特曼秀。他们去杰·雷诺秀。他们讲讲小笑话。他们试图展现魅力，所有这些都是为了跳出那些政治口号（sound bites）。
Outside the sound bites. Today on our program, driven by the same desperate impulse, we also try to escape the world of the sound bite. We have three different stories about parts of this selection that do not fit into the scripted, pre-planned soundbites that we'll be hearing from the candidates over the next few days.
跳出政治口号。今天在我们的节目中，出于同样绝望的冲动，我们也试图逃离政治口号的世界。我们有三个关于这次选举的故事，它们并不符合未来几天我们会从候选人那里听到的那种照本宣科、预先规划好的政治口号。
Act One, Fools Rush In, where sound bites fear to tread. Jack Hitt reports on a multimillionaire who helped swing this winter's Michigan primary by trashing mainstream pols in a very un-focus-grouped way, and what he has planned for these next few days before the general election. Act Two, Take Out Your Number Two Pencil, in which we look at the issue behind the issue behind a sound bite. And if that's confusing, well, just stay with me. Act Three, Nepotism a Beginner's Guide, and a defense. Adam Davidson discovers that he has the same blue blood ancestors as George W. Bush and wonders where his family went wrong, and where the Bushes went right, and why it takes 220 years to get to the point where you get to say the sound bite.
第一幕，“傻瓜闯入”，在政治口号不敢涉足的地方。杰克·希特报道了一位千万富翁，他通过以一种非常规的焦点小组方式痛批主流政客，帮助扭转了今年冬天的密歇根州初选，以及他为大选前最后几天准备的计划。第二幕，“拿出你的二号铅笔”，我们探讨政治口号背后的深层议题。如果这听起来很困惑，好吧，请留下来听。第三幕，“任人唯亲：初学者指南及辩护”。亚当·戴维森发现他和乔治·W·布什拥有相同的蓝血祖先，并想知道他的家族在哪里走错了路，布什家族在哪里做对了，以及为什么需要220年才能达到那个可以说出那句政治口号的地步。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And remember, for the next hour, I will fight for you. So stay with me.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请记住，在接下来的一个小时里，我会为你而战。所以请留下来。
Act One: Fools Rush In. So in these days when we yearn for more of our politicians to shoot from the hip a little more than they do, Jack Hitt found somebody who fit the bill, a former gubernatorial candidate in Michigan. Jack tells the story.
第一幕：傻瓜闯入。所以，在如今我们渴望更多政客能比现在更直言不讳的时候，杰克·希特找到了一个符合条件的人，一位密歇根州的前州长候选人。杰克讲述了这个故事。
Last February, I was sitting in the office of the multimillionaire Michigan trial lawyer Geoffrey Fieger. You'll remember he was Jack Kevorkian's lawyer. And he was also the lawyer who once walked into court carrying a big picture of the prosecutor, his opponent, with a clown nose pinned on. I was trying to figure out Fieger wins hundreds of millions of dollars while using tactics most people find outrageous, even insane. But I could barely get in a question, because it was just a few days away from the Michigan Republican primary, and Fieger was incensed George W. Bush might win.
去年二月，我坐在密歇根州千万富翁出庭律师杰弗里·菲格的办公室里。你还记得他是杰克·科沃基恩的律师。他也是那个曾经带着一张他的对手——检察官的照片走进法庭的律师，照片上给检察官画了一个小丑鼻子。我一直试图弄明白菲格是如何在使用大多数人认为离谱甚至疯狂的策略的同时，还能赢得数亿美元的诉讼。但我几乎插不上话，因为距离密歇根州共和党初选只有几天了，菲格很气愤乔治·W·布什可能会赢。
Remember how it was last winter. Bush had just barely defeated John McCain in the South Carolina primary, and Michigan's governor, John Engler, had declared his state to be Bush's, quote, "firewall" against McCain. On that cold afternoon, Fieger's phone rang every two minutes. It was a couple of his pals, who were encouraging Fieger to make some negative ads attacking Bush in order to humiliate Governor Engler. Less than 24 hours later, Michigan voters began hearing Fieger's ad.
还记得去年冬天的情况吗。布什在南卡罗来纳州初选中以微弱优势击败了约翰·麦凯恩，而密歇根州州长约翰·恩格勒宣布他的州是布什对抗麦凯恩的“防火墙”。那个寒冷的下午，菲格的电话每两分钟就响一次。是他的几个伙伴，鼓励菲格制作一些攻击布什的负面广告，以羞辱恩格勒州长。不到24小时后，密歇根选民开始听到菲格的广告。
Hi, this is Geoff Fieger. They're back. Listen to this.
嗨，我是杰夫·菲格。他们回来了。听听这个。
George W. Bush's record of results speaks for itself.
乔治·W·布什的执政业绩有目共睹。
As governor, he demanded higher standards for schools--
作为州长，他要求提高学校标准——
--fought trial lawyers over lawsuit abuse and beat them.
——在诉讼滥用问题上打击并击败了出庭律师。
What? When they say they ended lawsuit abuse, they mean we got screwed. Supporting--
什么？当他们说结束了诉讼滥用时，意思是我们要倒大霉了。支持——
The ad is a whole minute of in-your-face vitriol, right up to the sign-off.
这个广告整整一分钟都是咄咄逼人的尖酸刻薄，直到最后。
Paid for by Citizens against Dumb and Dumber.
由“反对笨蛋与更笨蛋公民组织”付费制作。
Here's the catch: it worked. At least, George Bush thought it did. The day he lost Michigan, he was blaming Fieger, by name, for interfering in the Republican primary. Months later, with Michigan heading towards another incredibly close presidential contest, Fieger and his buddies decided to do it all over again, just one week before election day.
关键在于：它奏效了。至少，乔治·布什是这么认为的。在他输掉密歇根州的那天，他指名道姓地指责菲格干预了共和党初选。几个月后，随着密歇根州再次迎来另一场极其接近的总统竞选，菲格和他的伙伴们决定在大选前一周再次这样做。
I hopped a plane and met with Fieger's pals, the guys who helped write these ads, Eric Humphrey, a radio producer, and Leon Weiss, a lawyer. I wanted to know, were they a PAC, a special interest group? What were they?
我坐飞机见了菲格的伙伴，那些帮忙写这些广告的人，电台制作人埃里克·汉弗莱和律师里昂·韦斯。我想知道，他们是一个政治行动委员会，一个特殊利益集团吗？他们到底是什么？
The best description of us would be Jello. You can see it, but you just can't get your hands on it. It's like we're a loose-knit group of people who have some strong political beliefs. We do not represent the Democratic Party, the Republican Party, the Libertarian Party, or any other organization. I'd say that we're probably coffee outside of the cup. You just don't know what to do with us.
形容我们最好的词是“果冻”。你可以看到它，但就是抓不住它。我们就像是一群有着坚定政治信仰的松散组织。我们不代表民主党、共和党、自由意志党或其他任何组织。我想我们大概是杯子外面的咖啡。你根本不知道该拿我们怎么办。
And they are coffee outside the cup. In this day of focus groups and marketing demographics and niches like suburban males, 18 to 24 years old, their idea of a target audience sounds totally antique.
他们确实是杯子外面的咖啡。在如今这个焦点小组、营销人口统计学以及诸如18到24岁郊区男性这种利基市场的时代，他们所谓的受众定位听起来完全是古董级别的。
Somebody who still has an open mind and maybe has a sense of humor.
那些仍然保持开放心态，可能还有幽默感的人。
They only do radio ads, in part because they're so effective in a state obsessed with cars and driving, and also because it's cheaper than one might think to get into the political game. On these ads, they might spend $20,000.
他们只做电台广告，部分原因是因为在这样一个痴迷于汽车和驾驶的州，它们非常有效，也因为进入政治游戏比人们想象的要便宜。在这些广告上，他们可能花费2万美元。
It's like a grain of sand on the beach.
就像沙滩上的一粒沙子。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
$10,000 or $15,000 or maybe $20,000, as opposed to, what, $40  million, $50 million that they spend on television, especially in the last two months. So it's nothing. It's a mosquito on an elephant's hind quarter.
1万美元或1.5万美元，或者2万美元，而不是他们在电视上花掉的4000万或5000万美元，尤其是在最后两个月里。所以这根本不算什么。就像大象后腿上的一只蚊子。
What do you think about the ads that the two candidates are running these days? What are the ads like here in Michigan?
你觉得这两个候选人现在播出的广告怎么样？密歇根州的广告是什么样的？
They are totally ridiculous. It is sickening.
它们完全是荒谬的。令人作呕。
And boring.
而且无聊。
And boring. I want to literally throw my television set out of the window. You've got negative ads against George Bush from Al Gore. You've got George Bush with negative ads against Al Gore. Then you've got Al Gore and George Bush both sitting in classrooms, hugging little black children.
而且无聊。我真的想把电视机从窗户扔出去。阿尔·戈尔有针对乔治·布什的负面广告。乔治·布什有针对阿尔·戈尔的负面广告。然后你看到阿尔·戈尔和乔治·布什都坐在教室里，拥抱黑人小孩子。
I mean, c'mon. Knock it off. Tell us something.
我的天，别闹了。告诉我们点什么吧。
By late afternoon, we had adjourned to the offices of WJR Radio in Detroit to work further on the scripts, when there was a commotion. Feiger swept into the studio like a conquering hero, dressed in an expensive blue pinstripe suit and muted red tie. He looked like Bush or Gore during the first debate, except for his hair, shaggy '70s retro. He was obviously still high from the euphoria one must experience from asking a jury for $150 million dollars and knowing you might get it.
傍晚时分，我们休会到底特律WJR电台的办公室继续修改剧本，这时发生了一阵骚动。菲格像个凯旋的英雄一样走进录音室，穿着昂贵的蓝色细条纹西装，戴着暗红色的领带。他看起来就像第一次辩论时的布什或戈尔，除了他的头发，那是70年代复古风格的蓬松发型。他显然还沉浸在向陪审团索要1.5亿美元并知道自己可能会得手的那种快感中。
Once Fieger took his seat in front of the studio microphone, Eric and Leon became noticeably more subdued, a typical moment. Eric had come up with a new line for Fieger.
菲格在演播室麦克风前坐好后，埃里克和里昂明显变得拘谨了许多，这是个典型的时刻。埃里克为菲格想出了一句新台词。
Well, let's do that. Write that out.
好吧，我们就那样做。把它写下来。
OK.
好的。
You could write that out right now. I like that.
你现在就可以写下来。我喜欢这个。
I am.
我在写。
But you got to have a lot more than just that. That's about 10 seconds.
但你不能只有那一点。那只有大约10秒钟。
OK.
好的。
Go.
开始。
Talk about Al-- OK. I gave you one pen. I gave him the other one.
谈谈阿尔——好的。我给了你一支笔。我给了他另一支。
Here's your pen back. No, you can't have my pen back.
这是你的笔，还给你。不，你不能要回我的笔。
Ah, the creative process. So Feiger took his pen back.
啊，创作过程。所以菲格把他的笔要了回来。
Just a minute.
等一下。
I thought by coming to WJR, what I would witness was the contemporary making of a Willie Horton ad, the most famous attack ad in contemporary politics, not officially sanctioned by either party, and so, able to put out a distorted, racist message about Michael Dukakis in 1988. But all day long, I was amazed to witness an unusual integrity on display. Fieger and his pals wanted to ridicule Bush viciously, but they were sort of prissy about it, surprisingly concerned that everything in the ad be true. When Leon wanted a line saying "Texas leads the country in water pollution," Eric struck it, arguing that Texas was only 49th. Again, here's Fieger.
我本以为来到WJR，我会见证现代版“威利·霍顿”广告的诞生，那是现代政治中最著名的攻击性广告，没有得到任何一方的正式批准，因此能够在1988年发布关于迈克尔·杜卡基斯的扭曲的、种族主义的信息。但整整一天，我很惊讶地看到了一种不同寻常的诚信。菲格和他的伙伴们想要恶毒地嘲笑布什，但他们对此又有点讲究，出奇地关心广告中的每一件事是否真实。当里昂想加一句“德克萨斯州的水污染在全国名列前茅”时，埃里克把它划掉了，理由是德克萨斯州只排在第49位。还是菲格的话。
The general political ads that are out there are horrible, just absolutely horrible. They're an insult to my intelligence, because they're lies, generally lies, just out-and-out complete lies. Our ads, frankly, are impeccably researched and empirically correct.
市面上的那些一般政治广告很可怕，绝对可怕。它们是对我智商的侮辱，因为它们是谎言，通常是谎言，彻头彻尾的完全谎言。坦率地说，我们的广告是经过无可挑剔的研究，并且在经验上是正确的。
There was a kind of internal logic even to the boundaries of their own bad taste. A Monica Lewinsky ad? No. A bunch of bad Jewish jokes about how Lieberman would save the country money by buying wholesale? Nixed. At one point, Geoffrey started scribbling madly on a yellow legal pad and then told everyone to hush. He said he'd had a divine inspiration and wanted to try out a new ad concept.
即使在他们自己糟糕品味的界限内，也有一种内在逻辑。莫妮卡·莱温斯基的广告？不行。一堆关于利伯曼如何通过批发购买为国家省钱的糟糕犹太笑话？否决。有一次，杰弗里开始在黄色法律便笺簿上疯狂地乱写，然后告诉大家安静。他说他得到了神圣的灵感，想尝试一个新的广告概念。
Hi, this is Jesus Christ. And I'm a little pissed. I said, "Thou shall not kill." What don't you understand about that? For example, George W. Bush. He's got a death toll higher than Slobodan Milosevic. And you guys want to make him the most powerful man in the world? Are you nuts? Vote for Bush and piss off the Lord.
嗨，我是耶稣基督。我有点生气。我说过，“不可杀人。”你们对这话有什么不理解的吗？例如，乔治·W·布什。他的死亡人数比斯洛博丹·米洛舍维奇还要高。而你们这些人想让他成为世界上最有权势的人？你们疯了吗？投布什一票，让上帝生气吧。
Oh, cut it out. Cut it out.
哦，删掉。删掉。
Piss off the Lord.
让上帝生气。
What was amazing about the whole experience was how much fun they were all having. It's hard to capture the madness and pleasure that filled the room. Obviously, it was mean-spirited, but it's a pleasure you almost never see in our formal public politics.
整个经历最令人惊奇的是他们玩得有多开心。很难捕捉到房间里那种疯狂和愉悦感。显然，这带有恶意，但这是我们在正规公共政治中几乎从未见过的乐趣。
I don't think anyone has fun. But everything that we do, at least me, I can't speak for everybody else, it's only interesting for me if I have fun. Now for some reason, the idea of fun in this whole thing is either not accepted or rejected, or looked down upon. I don't know why. But I'll tell you that that's the way I feel about everything that I do.
我觉得没人玩得开心。但我们做的每一件事，至少对我来说，我不能代表其他人，只有我玩得开心才有意义。现在出于某种原因，在这种事情里追求乐趣要么不被接受，要么被拒绝，要么被看不起。我不知道为什么。但我会告诉你，这就是我对所有事情的感受。
I mean life is so short. I just looked around, and I was 18 years old. And I'm 49, going on 50. Man, that's so fast. If you don't have fun, what's your excuse for being?
我的意思是人生如此短暂。我环顾四周，曾经我是18岁。现在我快50岁了。天哪，太快了。如果你不享受乐趣，你存在的理由是什么？
Isn't this the kind of unscripted spirit most of us say is missing from our mainstream politicians? While it's easy to do this from the sidelines, the question is, can you have this much fun if you're the candidate and then go on to win? In fact, Fieger ran for governor in 1998 and lost. He lost, in large part, because his opponent reminded voters that Fieger regularly said shocking things, like the time he referred to Jesus as, quote, "just some goofball that got nailed to the cross."
这不就是我们大多数人所说的，从我们的主流政客身上缺失的那种非脚本式的精神吗？虽然站在场边做这件事很容易，但问题是，如果你是候选人，你能玩得这么开心然后继续赢得选举吗？事实上，菲格在1998年竞选州长时输了。他输掉的主要原因是他不仅被对手提醒选民菲格经常说些令人震惊的话，就像他曾经把耶稣称为“只是一个被钉在十字架上的傻瓜”的那一次。
If you ask Fieger about it, he'll tell you it's taken out of context. But I've read the full quote. And it's pretty bad. He says believing in Jesus is just as silly as Elvis mania. People had a reason to be insulted.
如果你去问菲格，他会告诉你那是断章取义。但我读过完整的引言。那真的很糟糕。他说相信耶稣和猫王热一样愚蠢。人们有理由感到被冒犯。
And that's the problem with shoot-from-the-hip politics. And yet, maybe the whole experience made him a little more careful. Over the course of two hours, he calls every soul who passes the glass window into the studio.
这就是直言不讳政治的问题所在。然而，也许整个经历让他变得更加谨慎了。在两个小时的时间里，他把每一个路过玻璃窗走进录音室的人都叫了过来。
Go bring that girl in here. And I want to see what she thinks of it.
去把那个女孩带进来。我想看看她对此有什么想法。
I don't know where she is.
我不知道她在哪里。
Just go ask. They'll get her.
去问问就行了。他们会把她找来的。
And to every one, he plays his "Hi, this is Jesus Christ" ad.
对每一个人，他都播放那个“嗨，我是耶稣基督”的广告。
Hi. This is Jesus Christ. And I'm a little pissed.
嗨，我是耶稣基督。我有点生气。
Every time, it cracks everybody up. And every time, Leon and Eric try to talk him out of it.
每次，这都会让所有人大笑。而且每次，里昂和埃里克都试图劝阻他。
You're crazy.
你疯了。
Rejected.
拒绝。
Right now, you've got the Jews, the blacks, and the Catholics all over your ass.
现在，犹太人、黑人和天主教徒都在盯着你了。
And this is the one time I watch them oppose Fieger on a big issue and actually convince him. After two and a half hours, they finish two 60-second ads complete with sound effects and music. "We're like the Beatles," Fieger says. Here's one of the ads.
这是我第一次看到他们在一个大问题上反对菲格，并成功说服了他。两个半小时后，他们完成了两个60秒的广告，配上了音效和音乐。“我们就像披头士乐队，”菲格说。这是其中一个广告。
Hi, this is Geoff Fieger. George W. Bush has never accomplished anything on his own in his entire life. Let's take a look.
嗨，我是杰夫·菲格。乔治·W·布什一生中从未靠自己成就过任何事情。让我们来看看。
You don't have the qualifications for Yale, my boy.
你没有进入耶鲁的资格，孩子。
My daddy's George Bush.
我的爸爸是乔治·布什。
Welcome to Yale, my boy.
欢迎来到耶鲁，孩子。
You don't have the qualifications for Harvard Business School.
你没有进入哈佛商学院的资格。
My daddy's George Bush.
我的爸爸是乔治·布什。
His ads sound highly produced and planned out, yet the whole process was so improvisational. And Fieger himself is completely unreflective, to the point that when I kept asking him to talk about the strategy of the ad, he got a little mad at me.
他的广告听起来制作精良，策划周密，但整个过程又是如此即兴。菲格本人完全不善反思，以至于当我不断要求他谈论广告策略时，他对我有点生气。
We don't give a damn. We just do it.
我们才不在乎。我们只是做了。
And who, in your mind, whose vote do you think you're swaying?
在你看来，你认为你在撼动谁的选票？
I don't know. I'm telling you, if it's possible--
我不知道。我告诉你，如果可能的话——
How do you think this reacts on somebody who hears it?
你认为这对听到它的人有什么影响？
I don't know. You're asking me to analyze this, and then be absolutely serious and intellectually delve into the thing. And I don't do that. It would ruin the spontaneity. And let me just tell you this, OK? That's why it's so good.
我不知道。你是在要求我分析这个，然后一本正经地深入研究它。我不做那种事。那会破坏自发性。让我告诉你这个，好吗？这就是为什么它这么好。
The political ads that Fieger makes are the ones we voters allegedly find the most horrifying, unaccountable attacks not affiliated with any candidate saying the worst possible things. And I wondered if the populist part of Fieger might think there's something wrong with the idea that any rich guy can get on the air and take potshots at any politician he wants. But I was wrong.
菲格制作的政治广告是我们选民理应感到最恐怖的，那些与任何候选人无关、说出最糟糕话语的、不可追究责任的攻击。我想知道菲格的平民主义一面是否会认为，任何富人都可以上电视并随意攻击任何政客这种想法有什么问题。但我错了。
Fieger thinks there should be more of these ads, that everyone should get in on the game. And when he told me this, I realized that what Fieger's up to isn't part of the new wave of negative advertising, but actually is connected to something very old-fashioned in American politics, the pure public glee of calling the other side names.
菲格认为应该有更多这样的广告，每个人都应该参与进来。当他告诉我这一点时，我意识到菲格所做的不是负面广告新浪潮的一部分，而是与美国政治中非常古老的东西联系在一起——那种痛骂对方阵营的纯粹公共快感。
This is the way it always was. In 1884, the fact that Grover Cleveland had had a child out of wedlock had Republicans marching down the street, delightedly singing, "Ma, Ma, where's my pa?" And Democrats would shout back, "Gone to the White House, ha, ha, ha."
事情一直都是这样。1884年，格罗弗·克利夫兰婚外有子的事实让共和党人走上街头，高兴地唱着，“妈，妈，爸爸在哪儿？”而民主党人会喊回去，“去白宫了，哈哈哈。”
It does seem like you're all having a lot of fun in there.
看起来你们在里面确实玩得很开心。
Anything we do, it's got to be fun.
任何我们做的事情，都必须有趣。
That's why it's so good. If it's not fun, we wouldn't do it.
这就是为什么它这么好。如果不好玩，我们就不会做。
Do you think they're having fun over at the Gore campaign tonight?
你觉得戈尔阵营的人今晚玩得开心吗？
No. They're talking about prescription drugs and Social Security and $1,500 and $30,000 and $20,000.
不。他们谈论的是处方药和社会保障，还有1500美元和3万美元和2万美元。
We just have fun. We have fun. It's fun. That's what it is.
我们只是玩得开心。我们玩得开心。这很有趣。事实就是这样。
How many people have you heard, just today, say, "I can't wait until this damn election is over"? Everybody hates it. There is no joy in our politics, no pleasure. No one's laughing, except, it seems, Geoffrey Fieger, who's having a ball, and now signs all of his ads with his trademark bellowing laugh.
你今天听到多少人说，“我等不及这该死的选举结束了”？每个人都讨厌它。我们的政治中没有快乐，没有享受。没人笑，除了杰弗里·菲格，他玩得非常开心，现在他所有的广告都以他标志性的吼笑声结束。
Paid for by the Committee against Dumb, Dumber, and Dumbest.
由“反对笨蛋、更笨蛋和最笨蛋委员会”付费制作。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Jack Hitt lives in Connecticut. Coming up, how many grandparents and great-grandparents and great-great-grandparents do you have to have with the middle names Herbert and Walker for you to become president yourself? You ain't seen nothing yet. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
杰克·希特住在康涅狄格州。接下来，你需要有多少个中间名是赫伯特和沃克的祖父母、曾祖父母和曾曾祖父母，才能让你自己成为总统？你还没看到真正的精彩之处。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Outside the Sound Bites, in which we try to avoid, sidestep, or look beneath the presidential candidates' talking points in these final days before the election. We've arrived at Act Two of our show, Take Out Your Number Two Pencil.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，主题是“跳出政治口号”，我们将尝试在选举前最后几天避开、绕过或审视总统候选人的竞选纲领。我们来到了节目的第二幕，“拿出你的二号铅笔”。
One thing that is striking about this presidential race is that the two big issues, that the two big candidates debate most, are two things that most of us do not really understand at all, prescription drug policy and school accountability. And so the candidates throw their little catchwords back and forth. And how are we supposed to evaluate that? It is as if we're supposed to choose between them based on their stances on Fermat's Last Theorem. So our producer, Alex Blumberg, looked behind what they have to say about education, and found that the reality is dismayingly different from their little speeches.
这次总统大选的一个显著之处是，两位主要候选人辩论最多的两个大议题，是我们大多数人根本不了解的——处方药政策和学校问责制。所以候选人抛来抛去他们的小口号。而我们该如何评估呢？就好像我们要根据他们对费马大定理的立场来在这两者之间做出选择。所以我们的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格研究了他们在教育方面的说法，发现现实与他们的演讲大相径庭。
There are differences, fairly big ones, between the Bush and Gore education plans. Gore wants more money for early childhood education and teacher training. Bush wants vouchers for families in failing schools. But at the heart of both their education plans is the idea that kids should be tested and tested often, to be sure they're being taught well.
布什和戈尔的教育计划之间存在差异，而且相当大。戈尔希望为幼儿教育和教师培训投入更多资金。布什希望为进入失败学校的家庭提供代金券。但他们教育计划的核心都是认为应该对孩子进行测试，而且要经常测试，以确保他们受到良好的教育。
Look, we agree on a couple of things on education. I strongly support new accountability. So does Governor Bush. I'm in favor of testing as a way of measuring performance, every school, every school district. Have every state test the children. I've also proposed--
看，我们在教育方面有几点达成了一致。我强烈支持新的问责制。布什州长也是。我赞成将测试作为衡量绩效的一种方式，每所学校、每个学区。让每个州都测试孩子。我还提议——
We're going to say, if you receive federal money, measure third grade, fourth grade, fifth grade, sixth grade, seventh grade, eighth grade, and show us whether or not children are learning to read and write and add and subtract. And if so, there'll be a bonus plan, instead of continuing to subsidize failure. Testing is the cornerstone of reform. You know how I know?
我们要说的是，如果你接受联邦资金，请衡量三年级、四年级、五年级、六年级、七年级、八年级，并向我们展示孩子是否在学习阅读、写作、加法和减法。如果是这样，将会有奖励计划，而不是继续补贴失败。测试是改革的基石。你知道我怎么知道的吗？
In the first presidential debate, the only argument about tests was who had more of them, and whose were tougher on kids and teachers.
在第一场总统辩论中，关于测试的唯一争论是谁的测试更多，谁的测试对孩子和老师更严格。
Well, first of all, I do have mandatory testing. I think the governor may not have heard what I said clearly. All schools, all school districts, students themselves, and required teacher testing, which goes a step farther than Governor Bush has been willing to go.
嗯，首先，我确实有强制性测试。我认为州长可能没有听清我刚才的话。所有学校、所有学区、学生自己，以及要求的教师测试，这比布什州长愿意做的更进一步。
North Carolina is one of a handful of states in the country that's already adopted an education plan similar to what both candidates are talking about. It's called the ABC program, and it's based on the same simple premise both candidates propose. We hold schools accountable for teaching our kids. The schools that do well, we reward. The ones that don't, we demand changes. And the way we tell, a standardized test.
北卡罗来纳州是全国为数不多已经采用类似于两位候选人所谈论的教育计划的州之一。它被称为ABC计划，其依据是两位候选人提出的同一个简单前提。我们要让学校对教育我们的孩子负责。表现好的学校，我们奖励。表现不好的，我们要求改变。而衡量的方法，就是标准化测试。
I talked to teachers from five schools across the state. And what they said is the reality isn't as simple as the campaign rhetoric makes it seem, and that North Carolina's accountability program has consequences, both good and bad, that interestingly, neither candidate seems to mention.
我和州内五所学校的老师谈过。他们说的是，现实并不像竞选口号看起来那么简单，北卡罗来纳州的问责计划既有好的后果，也有坏的后果，有趣的是，两位候选人似乎都没有提到。
So how many tests have you taken this year?
所以你今年参加了多少次测试？
About four, the computer competency test, the end of quarter test, the reading end of quarter test, and there was a practice computer competency test.
大约四次，计算机能力测试、学期末测试、学期末阅读测试，还有一次练习用的计算机能力测试。
And what's the date today?
今天是什么日期？
October 18.
10月18日。
Kids in North Carolina take a lot of tests. In some schools, as many as 30 days out of the year are given over to tests. And the most important tests of all, the tests everyone talks about, the tests from which all other tests originate, are called the EOGs, or End-of-Grade tests. Every kid from third grade to eighth grade takes them.
北卡罗来纳州的孩子们参加很多测试。在一些学校，一年中有长达30天的时间用于考试。所有考试中最重要的一项，每个人都在谈论的考试，所有其他测试的源头，被称为EOG，即“学年末测试”。从三年级到八年级的每个孩子都要参加。
Nearly all the teachers I talked to said that a lot has improved since North Carolina started its educational reforms in 1996. There's a new curriculum, which the teachers like. Teacher salaries have increased. And more resources are going to early childhood programs. But when talking about the EOGs, a lot of the teachers use words like frenzy, mania, or in some cases monster.
我交谈过的几乎所有老师都说，自从北卡罗来纳州1996年开始教育改革以来，很多方面都有所改善。有一个新的课程体系，老师们很喜欢。教师工资提高了。更多的资源流向了早期教育项目。但在谈论EOG时，许多老师使用了“疯狂”、“狂热”或者在某些情况下是“怪物”这样的词。
That's because a lot is riding on the EOGs. School scores are published in local papers and on the internet. They show up in real estate listings. Principals of chronically low-performing schools can be fired. Teachers at schools that score well on the tests or show marked improvement receive bonuses that go as high as $1,500 per teacher.
这是因为EOG事关重大。学校成绩会发表在当地报纸和互联网上。它们会出现在房地产挂牌信息中。表现长期不佳的学校的校长可能会被解雇。在考试成绩优异或有显著进步的学校工作的教师，可以获得高达每人1500美元的奖金。
But teachers have enough questions about the testing that some of them have turned down the money when it's offered. And in North Carolina's fifth year of reform, the issues have heated up enough that many educators get edgy talking about it publicly. One state official hung up on me in the middle of a conversation. At a school in Hallsboro, the principal, Lynn Spaulding wouldn't let me talk to any of his teachers without him being present. And then there's Teresa Glenn.
但教师们对测试有足够的疑问，以至于当奖金提供时，一些人拒绝接受。在北卡罗来纳州改革的第五年，这些问题已经引起了足够的反响，以至于许多教育工作者公开谈论它时感到紧张。一位州官员在谈话中途挂断了我的电话。在Hallsboro的一所学校，校长林恩·斯伯丁不允许我在没有他在场的情况下与他的任何老师交谈。然后还有特蕾莎·格伦。
My name is Teresa Glenn. I teach eighth grade language arts and social studies. And I've been teaching for three and a half years.
我的名字是特蕾莎·格伦。我教八年级的语言艺术和社会研究。我已经教了三年半了。
And where do you teach?
你在哪里教书？
I teach in Montgomery County, North Carolina, which is in the south-central part of North Carolina.
我在北卡罗来纳州的蒙哥马利县教书，它位于北卡罗来纳州的中南部。
All right. And are you in school right now?
好的。你现在在学校吗？
No, I'm not in school.
不，我不在学校。
And why is that?
那是为什么？
I'm serving a suspension for discussing the North Carolina End-of-Grade tests.
我因为讨论北卡罗来纳州的学年末测试正在接受停职处分。
On May 28 of this year, Teresa Glenn posted an impassioned email message to a North Carolina educational list server, hosted by the North Carolina Department of Public Instruction. In nine paragraphs, she outlined her various concerns with the EOGs. In the last one, she summarized.
今年5月28日，特蕾莎·格伦在北卡罗来纳州教育列表服务器上发布了一封激情的电子邮件，该服务器由北卡罗来纳州公共教育部托管。在九段话中，她概述了她对EOG的各种担忧。在最后一段中，她做了总结。
And the last paragraph, I talked about some of the things I saw last year with my students. And I said, "I apologize if anyone is offended by any of the above. I'm personally offended by the EOG tests.
在最后一段，我谈到了去年我与学生们一起看到的一些事情。我说，“如果以上内容冒犯了任何人，我表示歉意。我个人被EOG测试冒犯了。
I've seen students, good, solid, A, B students crying because of the tests. I've seen students who work hard but lack the native intelligence to pass a two-hour multiple choice test retained. I've seen teachers do nothing for the last 6 to 10 weeks of school but work on EOG preparation.
我见过好的、踏实的、拿A和B的学生因为测试而哭泣。我见过努力工作但缺乏通过两小时多项选择测试所必需的天赋的学生留级。我见过老师在学年最后6到10周里除了准备EOG什么都不做。
I've seen teachers publicly humiliated because they had lower test scores than the year before. I've seen children made fun of, called names, and put down based on their EOG scores. I've seen teachers look down their noses because a child is a three, three on the EOG test and not a three, four. The entire spectacle is disgusting."
我见过老师因为测试分数比前一年低而受到公开羞辱。我见过孩子因为他们的EOG分数被嘲笑、起绰号和贬低。我见过老师因为孩子在EOG测试中得3分而不是4分而瞧不起他们。整个景象令人作呕。”
The part of the email that got her in trouble was the part where she discussed the specific content of two questions on last year's reading EOG. She pointed out that the two questions required students to know information that wasn't in the reading passage they were supposedly being tested on. Not long after that email, her principal called her into his office and told her the state was considering revoking her teaching certificate.
让她惹上麻烦的部分是她讨论去年阅读EOG中两个特定问题的内容。她指出这两个问题要求学生知道的信息并没有包含在他们被测试的阅读文章中。那封邮件发出后不久，她的校长把她叫进办公室，告诉她州政府正在考虑吊销她的教师资格证。
To be perfectly honest with you, I was absolutely floored. And my principal called me. And I really like my principal. I think he's a very upstanding man.
老实说，我完全惊呆了。校长给我打电话。我真的很喜欢我的校长。我认为他是一个非常正直的人。
He called me into his office and said, "Did you say something on an email forum about the tests this year?" And I said, "Of course I did." And maybe I'm just naive, but it didn't occur to me that you can get in trouble for discussing the shortcomings of these tests, particularly when they are almost life and death, at least academically, for students. So I was very surprised.
他把我叫进办公室说，“你今年在邮件论坛上说了关于测试的事情吗？”我说，“我当然说了。”也许我只是太天真了，但我没想到讨论这些测试的缺点会惹上麻烦，尤其是当它们对于学生来说几乎是关乎生死，至少在学术上是这样的时候。所以我非常惊讶。
They eventually told Teresa that she'd violated an agreement she'd signed as part of the testing program that forbade her from paraphrasing any of the questions on the test in public. Teresa says the only reason she was allowed to keep your job, and got away with just a suspension, was that one of the local school board members present at her hearing owed her a favor. She says the big problem with the tests is how much time and resources have been diverted to them.
他们最终告诉特蕾莎，她违反了作为测试项目一部分所签署的协议，该协议禁止她公开转述测试中的任何问题。特蕾莎说她能保住工作并只受到停职处分的唯一原因，是出席她听证会的当地校董会成员之一欠她一个人情。她说测试的最大问题是为此分流了太多的时间和资源。
Some teachers in her school, she says, spend 50% to 75% of their classroom time on test prep. A huge chunk of the school's book budget has gone to buying four different test prep books for each student. She says no wonder administrators are so touchy.
她说，她学校的一些老师把50%到75%的课堂时间花在应试准备上。学校书籍预算中的很大一部分被用于为每个学生购买四种不同的备考书。她说难怪管理员如此敏感。
The amount of money that's been poured into this is immense. If somebody says, "This is not working. And you just wasted $500 million dollars on this program that's actually hurting kids," you have to think that there's going to be some kind of serious ramification for that person.
投入其中的资金是巨大的。如果有人说，“这行不通。你们刚刚在这个实际上伤害孩子的项目上浪费了5亿美元，”你必须认为那个人会面临某种严重的后果。
And you think that's what's happening, that $500 million has been poured into a program that's hurting kids?
你认为这就是正在发生的事情，5亿美元被投入到一个伤害孩子的项目中？
Well, I just got something yesterday in the mail from the Department of Public Instruction sort of bragging that somewhere over $100 million had been handed out in bonuses this year alone to teachers who were at these schools that have made the biggest gains.
嗯，我昨天从公共教育部收到了一些东西，他们似乎在吹嘘今年仅给那些取得最大进步的学校的老师发放了超过1亿美元的奖金。
What do you make of that?
你怎么看？
Well, on the personal level, it depresses me, because I've been asking still for the same two novel sets for the last two years, and I haven't gotten them.
嗯，在个人层面上，这让我感到沮丧，因为过去两年来我一直在要求同样的两个小说套装，但我没有拿到。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
What are you trying to get?
你想得到什么？
I just want Ender's Game by Orson Scott Card, who actually lives here in North Carolina. I just want 30 copies of it. And then there's another novel that I'd like, the Jon Krakauer Into Thin Air . That's the book about the climb to Mount Everest.
我只是想要奥森·斯科特·卡德的《安德的游戏》，他实际上就住在北卡罗来纳州。我只要30本。还有另一本我想读的小说，乔恩·克拉考尔的《进入空气稀薄地带》。那是关于攀登珠穆朗玛峰的书。
The kids would love that. They would be totally into it. Because it's gory enough that they'd be interested in it too. That's all I want in my pitiful life as an eighth grade teacher. And I don't foresee myself getting it.
孩子们会喜欢那本书的。他们会完全沉浸其中的。因为它足够血腥，他们也会感兴趣。这就是我在八年级老师这个可怜的生活中想要的全部。而且我预见不到我能得到它。
And I know we talk about high standards, but in my mind, just teaching students to answer multiple choice questions is about the lowest standard I can possibly imagine. That's not the same thing as having the skills to live a productive life in a democratic society. I think we're robbing the students of what education should be, which is a love of knowledge and the ability to pursue gaining more knowledge as you want to. And we're saying that the purpose of education is to pass these tests.
我知道我们谈论高标准，但在我看来，仅仅教会学生回答多项选择题是我能想象到的最低标准。这与拥有在民主社会中过上富有成效生活所需的技能不是一回事。我认为我们是在抢夺学生应得的教育，即对知识的热爱和在你需要时追求获得更多知识的能力。而我们却在说教育的目的是通过这些考试。
When I asked the North Carolina State Board of Education for a school where their plan was working, they sent me to Allenbrook Elementary in Charlotte. It's in a poor neighborhood and has a history of poor performance on the tests. Four years ago, the state assistance team came to Allenbrook to help it improve, the kind of thing Al Gore would like to see adopted everywhere.
当我向北卡罗来纳州教育委员会询问一个他们的计划正在奏效的学校时，他们把我送到了夏洛特的艾伦布鲁克小学。它位于一个贫困社区，有考试成绩不佳的历史。四年前，州援助小组来到艾伦布鲁克帮助其改善，这是阿尔·戈尔希望在各地采用的那种做法。
If it's a failing school, shut it down and reopen it under a new principal with a turnaround team of specialists, the way Governor Jim Hunt does in North Carolina. If it's a--
如果是一所失败的学校，关闭它，并在新校长和专家组成的转型团队的领导下重新开放，就像北卡罗来纳州的吉姆·亨特州长那样。如果是一个——
Actually, they don't shut the school down. But there was a team of specialists. And 70% of the staff either quit or was transferred. And the principal was removed. Cathy Hammond was his replacement. And under her leadership, the school has made remarkable gains on the test scores. And she readily credits the accountability program.
其实他们没有关闭学校。但确实有一个专家小组。70%的员工要么辞职要么被调离。校长被撤职。凯茜·哈蒙德是他的继任者。在她的领导下，学校在考试成绩上取得了显著进步。她欣然归功于问责计划。
I think our state is doing a phenomenal job of addressing the needs in education. When I taught, and I taught for 16 years in a middle school, I never had an administrator ask me, "Why are you teaching that? What is it you want your children to know that they didn't know before you started?" No one cared. As long as the children were in the room, everyone was quiet, the parents were happy, I could've been teaching leapfrog. So I like the idea that we have a set of standards that all children need to know, and that we're responsible for teaching them.
我认为我们的州在处理教育需求方面做得非常好。当我教书的时候，我在初中教了16年，我从来没有管理员问过我，“你为什么教那个？在你开始之前，你想让孩子们知道什么他们不知道的东西？”没人关心。只要孩子们在教室里，每个人都安静，家长们很高兴，我甚至可以教跳蛙。所以我喜欢我们有所有孩子都需要知道的一套标准，并且我们有责任教导他们。
Here's what they found when they tried to fix the school. First, the problem wasn't the teachers' ability. The state team evaluated all the teachers, and only one was rated below competent. The problem was there simply weren't enough of them, especially for the task of bringing Allenbrook's student population up to grade level. For whatever sociological reasons, kids from poor neighborhoods tend to do worse in school and worse on standardized tests. You can bring them up to speed, but you need extra teachers to do it.
这是他们试图修复学校时发现的情况。首先，问题不在于老师的能力。州小组评估了所有的老师，只有一个被评定为不称职以下。问题在于他们的人数实在太少了，尤其是对于让艾伦布鲁克的学生群体达到年级水平的任务。无论出于何种社会学原因，来自贫困社区的孩子往往在学校表现更差，在标准化测试中也更差。你可以让他们赶上来，但你需要额外的老师来做到这一点。
If you have a child that's coming to you that's coming out of an environment where they have not had a bed to sleep in, they've lost their parent for whatever reason, to incarceration or anything else, what do we as a school do about it in order to put support in for that child and that family? You cannot do that without adequate staff. You can't do that in a classroom with 25 children and one teacher.
如果一个孩子来到你身边，他来自一个没有床睡的环境，因为入狱或其他任何原因失去了父母，作为学校，我们该怎么做来为那个孩子和那个家庭提供支持？没有足够的员工，你无法做到这一点。你无法在一个有25个孩子和一位老师的教室里做到这一点。
Which raises the question, did the state need a test to fix Allenbrook School? Principal Hammond says what actually improved things was extra money, which she used to hire more reading teachers and a full-time social worker and a school psychologist. Why bother with the test? Why not just supply that?
这就提出了一个问题，州政府需要通过测试来修复艾伦布鲁克学校吗？哈蒙德校长说，真正改善情况的是额外的资金，她用这些钱雇用了更多的阅读老师、一名全职社会工作者和一名学校心理学家。为什么要费心进行测试？为什么不直接提供这些支持？
We know enough about how children learn and how children are successful to fix every school in America. It comes down to the question, do we have the will to do it, and are we willing to put the resources in the places that need them. I am not opposed to accountability. I think accountability is a great thing. I think sometimes we get carried away with the way we measure accountability, because it's more complex than a score on a test.
我们对孩子如何学习和如何取得成功了解得足够多，足以修复美国的每一所学校。归根结底，我们是否有决心去做，我们是否愿意把资源投入到需要的地方。我不反对问责制。我认为问责制是一件好事。我认为有时我们在衡量问责制的方式上走得太远，因为它比测试分数要复杂得多。
If what comes out of the national debate, say, is that the only thing that we need to make our schools better is a tough national test for everybody?
如果全国辩论的结果是，我们让学校变好的唯一方法就是对每个人进行严格的全国测试？
It scares me. It frustrates me that people think it's a simple fix, that we don't spend time talking about what does work. And one of the reasons we don't want to talk about what does work is because it takes a different level of commitment. It takes a different level of resources. And it takes a different kind of dialogue than a statement like, "I'm going to fix all of the schools in America."
这让我感到害怕。人们认为这是一个简单的解决方法，我们不花时间讨论什么才真正有效，这让我感到沮丧。我们不想谈论什么真正有效的原因之一是因为这需要不同程度的投入。这需要不同水平的资源。而且它需要比“我要修复美国所有的学校”这样的陈述更不同类型的对话。
She is maybe unintentionally proving our point, that if it had not been for the ABC Program and Allenbrook being embarrassed about being on the front page of The Charlotte Observer, the local community would have never put those additional resources in.
她可能在无意中证明了我们的观点，即如果不是因为ABC计划以及艾伦布鲁克因出现在《夏洛特观察家报》头版而感到尴尬，当地社区永远不会投入这些额外的资源。
This is Phil Kirk, Chairman of the North Carolina State Board of Education, and one of the two guys in charge of the ABC Program.
这是菲尔·柯克，北卡罗来纳州教育委员会主席，也是负责ABC计划的两个人之一。
Allenbrook would not have ever gotten those additional resources if the ABC Program hadn't embarrassed the school board. So she's made our point better than I could have.
如果不是ABC计划让校董会感到尴尬，艾伦布鲁克永远不会得到那些额外的资源。所以她比我更好地证明了我们的观点。
Phil Kirk says that he agrees with Principal Hammond, that it's harder to teach kids from poor backgrounds. You need more resources, more staff. He says he's gotten those things for poor schools, and he's trying to get even more. But the political reality is it's easier to get money from a state legislature if you can show them results.
菲尔·柯克说他同意哈蒙德校长的看法，即教导贫困背景的孩子更难。你需要更多的资源、更多的员工。他说他为贫困学校争取到了这些东西，并且正在努力争取更多。但政治现实是，如果你能向州立法机构展示结果，从他们那里获得资金就更容易。
If we didn't have ABC, we wouldn't be getting the additional resources for the low-performing schools. I believe that strongly. The state's investing a lot of money in the schools, and they want teachers to be more accountable. And we're not going to back off accountability.
如果我们没有ABC，我们就不会为表现不佳的学校获得额外的资源。我坚信这一点。州政府在学校投入了大量资金，他们希望老师们承担更多责任。我们不会放弃问责制。
A lot of teachers complain that politicians and people from the state use the language of business when talking about education. And many people are suspicious of the fact that Kirk is head of both the State Board of Education and the State Chamber of Commerce, in other words, the main education lobby and the main business lobby. But it's entirely possible that the same business vocabulary that raises suspicions among teachers is the very thing that makes him successful at getting money out of the legislature.
许多老师抱怨说，政客和州里的人在谈论教育时使用商业语言。许多人怀疑柯克同时担任州教育委员会和州商会负责人这一事实，换句话说，教育游说团体和商业游说团体的主力。但这完全有可能，让老师们产生怀疑的同样的商业词汇，正是使他成功从立法机构获得资金的原因。
He puts the concerns of education in language the legislature understands. Still, he can be pretty abrasive. He describes teachers who don't like the tests this way.
他用立法机构能理解的语言来表达教育方面的担忧。尽管如此，他还是相当尖刻。他这样描述不喜欢测试的老师。
They want business as usual. They can come up with every whiny excuse that they want to. But if anybody thinks their whining and complaining is going to cause us to get weak-kneed as we end social promotion and put in an exit exam, they've got another thought coming, because it's not going to happen.
他们想要照旧经营。他们可以想出各种抱怨的借口。但如果任何人认为他们的抱怨和唠叨会导致我们在终结社会推广并实行毕业考试时变得软弱，那他们就想错了，因为这不会发生。
This is a letter that I received. And it's a report of student performance on the second retest with the North Carolina Integrated Test.
这是我收到的一封信。这是关于学生在北卡罗来纳州综合测试第二次补考中的表现报告。
Cathy Rouse's youngest son, Carlton, was in third grade last year at Hallsboro-Artesia Elementary School. He got A's and B's. But he didn't pass his EOGs at the end of the year. And then he failed his two allowed retests, which meant he had to repeat third grade.
凯茜·劳斯最小的儿子卡尔顿去年在Hallsboro-Artesia小学读三年级。他拿了A和B。但他没通过年底的EOG。然后他没通过被允许的两次补考，这意味着他必须重读三年级。
I told him that I went to the school, and what the teacher had told me, that he hadn't passed. And I said, that means that they'll hold you back. And he cried hot tears. And he asked me, "Mama, what's wrong with me?" And that right there, that was it. It's more than a reading problem. That, to me, is the beginning of the onslaught on our children's psyche.
我告诉他我去学校了，老师告诉我他没通过。我说，这意味着他们会让你留级。他流下了滚烫的眼泪。他问我，“妈妈，我怎么了？”那一瞬间，就是那样。这不仅仅是一个阅读问题。对我来说，那是对我们孩子心理攻击的开始。
Cathy protested and put her case before the county board, and finally had Carlton promoted. He's in fourth grade this year. Between 1991 and 1997, 66 studies were done on holding kids back. 65 of them showed it to be either ineffectual or damaging in the long run. And a lot of times, it's just not necessary. Even in schools that start aggressive remediation in kindergarten, it's common not to see higher test scores until seventh or eighth grade. Third grade is just too early to tell if things are working. To Cathy Rouse, this is just common sense.
凯茜提出了抗议，并将她的案例提交给县委员会，最终卡尔顿被升入了四年级。他今年在读四年级。1991年至1997年间，针对让孩子留级进行了66项研究。其中65项研究表明，从长远来看，留级要么无效，要么有害。很多时候，这根本没有必要。即使在幼儿园就开始积极补习的学校，通常也要到七年级或八年级才能看到更高的测试分数。三年级还太早，无法判断事情是否有效。对凯茜·劳斯来说，这只是常识。
No test or anyone, especially anyone considering themselves an educator, can indicate what you're going to be when you're eight years old. We do not begin to categorize our children at eight years old, and stamp them and have them believe at eight years old that there's something wrong with them.
没有测试或任何人，特别是任何自认为是教育工作者的人，可以说明你八岁时会是什么样。我们不要在八岁时就开始给我们的孩子分类，给他们打上标签，让他们在八岁时就相信自己有什么问题。
And I told them, I don't know where I have to go. But I will not have that done to my child. I will not have him see himself as less than. Because seriously at eight years old, that's criminal. There are studies and all that on that, how much self-image and self-perception plays into learning.
我告诉他们，我不知道我该去哪里。但我绝不会让这种事发生在我的孩子身上。我绝不会让他觉得自己不如别人。因为认真说来，在八岁时做这种事是犯罪。关于自我形象和自我认知在学习中起多大作用，有很多研究。
Even among teachers who think the tests have made education better in North Carolina, like math teacher [? Mary Ann ?] Davis, this is a big worry. Not everyone will pass the tests. In the worst schools, over half the kids fail. Even in the very best, it's 10%. What happens to those kids?
即使在那些认为测试使北卡罗来纳州教育变得更好的老师中，比如数学老师[玛丽·安]·戴维斯，这也是一个巨大的担忧。不是每个人都能通过测试。在最差的学校，超过一半的孩子不及格。即使在最好的学校，也有10%。那些孩子会怎样？
?] Perhaps we are just assuming a higher level of competency than is possible for all children.
也许我们只是假设了一种高于所有儿童可能达到的能力水平。
What's the danger of that for the kids?
这对孩子们的危险是什么？
?] The danger of that is that we're asking them to be something that they just can't be. Putting a child at a desk with a chair and saying, "We're going to test you over and over until you can pass this, until you get it right," it's just not always going to happen. That's what I'm saying.
危险在于我们要求他们成为他们无法成为的人。把孩子放在桌子和椅子前，说：“我们要一遍又一遍地测试你，直到你能通过，直到你做对，”这并不总会发生。这就是我要说的。
To expect that every child in the state of North Carolina is going to reach a level three or four so that they can be promoted and so they can graduate is an unrealistic expectation. And having that unrealistic expectation is not fair to the children. We're taking it out on the kids, when it's not always the kids' fault.
期望北卡罗来纳州每一个孩子都能达到三级或四级，以便他们能够升学，能够毕业，这是一个不切实际的期望。拥有这种不切实际的期望对孩子们是不公平的。我们把气撒在孩子身上，而这并不总是孩子的错。
And that's sad. We shouldn't do that to children. That's abusive.
这很悲哀。我们不应该那样对待孩子。那是虐待。
This gets us to the crux of what Governor Bush might call "a difference in philosophy," the philosophy of teaching. How much should you demand results from students, on the one hand, versus how much you should nurture them on the other. Phil Kirk and the state legislature think things went too far towards nurture, and that it's time to go back the other way.
这就触及了布什州长可能称之为“哲学差异”的核心，即教学哲学。一方面，你应该在多大程度上要求学生取得成绩，另一方面，你应该在多大程度上培养他们。菲尔·柯克和州立法机构认为在培养方面做得太过头了，现在是时候朝另一个方向前进了。
A lot of the liberal-thinking people are more worried about self-esteem than they are about whether children can read and write. We don't buy that line.
许多自由派思维的人更担心自尊心，而不是孩子是否能读写。我们不买那套说辞。
At a school assembly in the Jefferson Elementary School gymnasium, I saw this philosophical divide for the gulf it truly is. Jefferson Elementary is set in a Winston-Salem suburb, filled with mature oaks and sprawling split-levels. Inside the school's carpeted classrooms, kids sit around work tables, not at desks, and quietly read or write in journals. Their art hangs from the walls, right above the height-appropriate bookshelves, next to the hamster cages and various aquaria.
在杰斐逊小学体育馆的一次学校集会上，我看到了这种哲学分歧导致的鸿沟。杰斐逊小学坐落在温斯顿-塞勒姆的郊区，种满了成熟的橡树，到处都是宽敞的分层住宅。在学校铺着地毯的教室里，孩子们围坐在工作台旁，而不是课桌前，安静地阅读或在日记中写作。他们的画作挂在墙上，就在合适高度的书架上方，旁边是仓鼠笼和各种水族箱。
Jefferson Elementary does very well on the EOGs, and today's assembly is because people from the state are here to congratulate them for it. Last year, for the first time, over 90% percent of Jefferson students scored above average on the EOGs, making it what the state calls "a school of excellence." Dr. Brad Sneeden, one of the state administrators, explains what this means.
杰斐逊小学的EOG成绩非常好，今天的集会是因为州政府的人来到这里祝贺他们。去年，这是第一次，超过90%的杰斐逊学生在EOG得分高于平均水平，使其成为州政府所称的“卓越学校”。州行政官布拉德·斯尼登博士解释了这意味着什么。
What has to be added to all that powerful leadership, that powerful teaching, that powerful nurturing, that powerful participation by others? What does it take to really get a school to a school of excellence? It takes you, doesn't it? It takes you to decide, "I'm here to learn." And you have done that. You're leaders. You are a leader. You're setting the stage. And we want many, many more to follow.
所有这一切强大的领导力、强大的教学、强大的培养、其他人强大的参与，还必须增加什么？真正让一所学校成为卓越学校需要什么？需要你们，不是吗？需要你们决定，“我是来学习的。”你们已经做到了。你们是领导者。你们是领导者。你们正在搭建舞台。我们希望有更多更多的人效仿。
Keep in mind, the group of leaders being addressed here is an auditorium full of schoolchildren with missing teeth and those gym shoes that light up. They're sitting cross-legged on the floor. And the shy ones are leaning against their teachers. Whatever message is reaching them from all this, it's probably not the one the speakers are intending. Witness this failed call-and-response attempt from Dr. Martin, the second presenter.
记住，这里所说的领导群体是一整个礼堂的学龄儿童，他们有缺牙，穿着会发光的运动鞋。他们盘腿坐在地板上。害羞的孩子正靠在他们的老师身上。无论所有这些向他们传达了什么信息，可能都不是演讲者想要传达的。见证一下马丁博士（第二位演讲者）这次失败的呼应尝试。
Now you all heard Dr. Sneeden. You all heard Dr. Sneeden speak about responsibility for doing your work. Remember, he said the final ingredient, after we have capable administrators, excellent teachers. I believe he used the word powerful teachers. The final ingredient is you guys, right? And so it takes responsibility for you doing your work and learning.
现在你们都听到了斯尼登博士的话。你们都听到了斯尼登博士谈论对完成工作的责任感。记住，他说最后的要素，在我们有了能干的行政人员、优秀的教师之后。我相信他用了“强大的老师”这个词。最后的要素是你们这些家伙，对吧？所以需要你们为完成工作和学习承担责任。
Now, where's the third grade? Third grade, why don't you guys stand up, because you're going to be taking the test this year for the first time. You'll be a part. So all of you are going to do what? Take responsibility. Good. All right. You guys can have a seat.
现在，三年级在哪里？三年级，你们为什么不站起来，因为你们今年将第一次参加测试。你们将成为其中的一部分。所以你们所有人都要做什么？承担责任。好。好了。你们可以坐下了。
Then Dr. Moser, Jefferson's principal, took the stage. He's an easy guy to love. He's sweet and soft-spoken and, if anything, a little embarrassed about this assembly. He readily admits that a large part of the reason his students score so well on the EOGs is simply that they come from well-off families. And when he addresses the students, he doesn't mention responsibility or leadership. It's all nurturing.
然后，杰斐逊小学的校长莫泽博士走上了台。他是个很容易让人喜欢的人。他温和、说话轻声细语，如果有什么的话，他会对这次集会感到有点尴尬。他欣然承认，他的学生在EOG上取得如此好成绩的很大一部分原因仅仅是因为他们来自富裕家庭。当他向学生讲话时，他没有提到责任或领导力。全是培养。
You all look so good. And it's always nice to get to look straight at you every day. Boys and girls, you know that we're very proud of you. We're proud of the work you do every day.
你们看起来都很好。每天能直视你们总是很高兴。孩子们，你们知道我们为你们感到非常自豪。我们为你们每天所做的工作感到自豪。
Teachers, I couldn't be more proud of the relationship and the atmospheres in your classrooms that allow our children to come every day and have a good experience here at school. You do a great job taking care of our boys and girls. And that's very important. And I think it's time for lunch.
老师们，对于你们教室里允许我们的孩子每天来到这里并在此获得良好体验的关系和氛围，我感到无比自豪。你们在照顾我们的孩子们方面做得很好。这非常重要。我想午餐时间到了。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
What's obvious is that each philosophy comes with its own language, the language of leadership versus the language of lunch. And each language emphasizes different things. In the teacher's lounge after the assembly, I'm swamped by teachers who are angry about the testing and how heavily it's being emphasized and how high the stakes are now. If the two competing impulses in American education are accountability on the one hand versus nurturing on the other, the consensus of these teachers and all the teachers I talked to across the state, is that obviously, you need both.
显而易见的是，每种哲学都有其自己的语言，领导力的语言与午餐的语言。每种语言强调不同的事情。集会后的老师休息室里，我被对测试感到愤怒的老师们包围了，他们对测试受到如此高度强调以及现在的风险如此之高感到不满。如果美国教育中两种竞争的冲动一方面是问责制，另一方面是培养，那么这些老师以及我在全州交谈过的所有老师的共识是，显然，你需要两者兼顾。
And even if the pendulum has swung too far in the direction of nurturing in the past, what George Bush and Al Gore are both proposing is to push it far in the other direction. What's needed is balance, the teachers said. But whichever man wins, that's probably not what we're going to see.
即使过去的天平过于倾向培养，但乔治·布什和阿尔·戈尔提出的都是将其推向另一个极端。老师们说，需要的是平衡。但无论哪个人赢了，那可能都不是我们将要看到的。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Act Three. So before we end our little election special, let's have a quick word about nepotism. In this country, where supposedly anybody can grow up to be president, we have one candidate who was raised in Washington, DC, son of a US senator, the other guy son of a president. And it's confusing to some of us, especially our contributor, Adam Davidson, who discovered recently that he and George Bush share six, that's right, six common ancestors, all of whom lived in 17th century England. Adam is wondering, how did this happen?
第三幕。所以，在结束我们的小选举特别节目之前，让我们简短谈谈任人唯亲。在这个国家，据称任何人都可以长大成为总统，我们有一位候选人在华盛顿特区长大，是美国参议员的儿子，另一个是总统的儿子。这让我们中的一些人感到困惑，尤其是我们的撰稿人亚当·戴维森，他最近发现他和乔治·布什有六个，没错，六个共同的祖先，他们都生活在17世纪的英国。亚当想知道，这是怎么发生的？
Where did my side of the dynasty go wrong? And what did his side do so right? Why did he get the presidential nomination handed to him, and I have to borrow money from my girlfriend to pay the rent?
我的那一方王朝哪里出错了？而他的一方做了什么正确的事？为什么他得到了总统提名，而我却不得不向我的女朋友借钱付房租？
I think it's probably true that George W. Bush is not all that bright. But he knows something, his whole family knows something. They know power. And they know how to get more and more power every generation.
我想乔治·W·布什可能确实没那么聪明，这是真的。但他知道一些事情，他的全家都知道一些事情。他们知道权力。而且他们知道如何每一代都获得越来越多的权力。
Well, Adam, you and George Bush are both descended from Experience Mitchell. And from the sister of Experience Mitchell was descended the late Princess of Wales.
嗯，亚当，你和乔治·布什都是Experience Mitchell的后裔。而通过Experience Mitchell的妹妹，也传承了已故威尔士王妃的血脉。
Presidential genealogist Gary Boyd Roberts.
总统家谱学家加里·博伊德·罗伯茨。
And so you, Prince William, and George Bush Senior and Junior are all about 9th or 10th cousins of each other through this one forebear. So this is a matter of one set of sixth to eighth cousins becoming social registerite American leaders, and the others remaining in small towns or small cities. And the ugly term for is quote, quote, "Swamp Yankee."
所以你、威廉王子，以及乔治·布什父子都是大约第九或第十代堂兄弟，通过这位先辈。所以这是一个关于第六到第八代堂兄弟中的一组成为社会名流美国领袖，而另一组留在了小城镇或小城市的问题。而它的丑陋术语是——引用引用——“沼泽扬基人”。
This is Gary Boyd Roberts's favorite game. He loves linking people. For him, there are no distant cousins. Mention any New England name, and he'll link them right up to queens and kings, to the Mayflower, to you, to me, to himself.
这是加里·博伊德·罗伯茨最喜欢的游戏。他喜欢连接人们。对他来说，没有遥远的堂兄弟。提到任何新英格兰名字，他就会把他们与女王和国王、五月花号、你、我、他自己联系起来。
He's a great genealogist. And he told me we could find out exactly where the Bushes went right and where my family went wrong.
他是一位伟大的家谱学家。他告诉我我们可以确切地找出布什家族做对了什么，而我的家族哪里做错了。
It all goes back to 1783, when my folks had a better piece of land than George's. That's where things started going south. It seems that the Bushes were forced to move out of town that year to get better farmland, while my family stayed put.
这一切可以追溯到1783年，那时我家族的人拥有比乔治家族更好的土地。那是事情开始走下坡路的地方。似乎布什家族那一年被迫搬离城镇以获得更好的农田，而我的家人留了下来。
Well, you see, these are people staying roughly-- I mean they may go five or six towns away-- but they stay in the Plymouth area from 1620 until 1886. That is 250 years.
嗯，你看，这些人大概一直待着——我的意思是他们可能搬到五六个城镇之外——但他们从1620年到1886年一直待在普利茅斯地区。那是250年。
Staying in the same small town.
待在同一个小镇。
Staying in the same spot. Whereas the world was moving elsewhere, meaning economic development and serious cities and finance and education had long since moved out of Plymouth.
待在同一个地方。而世界正在其他地方前进，意味着经济发展、大城市、金融和教育早已搬出了普利茅斯。
And just missed out on opportunities.
错过了机会。
Maybe that economic deprivation didn't force them to go anywhere.
也许那种经济匮乏并没有强迫他们去任何地方。
So they might have been just successful enough not to become incredibly successfully.
所以他们可能只是成功到不会变得极其成功。
Just successful enough not to feel they wanted to move, exactly.
刚好成功到不觉得他们想搬走，确实如此。
So let me recap this for you. The Bushes were our poor cousins. They weren't doing that well, so they decided to go somewhere else.
所以让我为你总结一下。布什家族是我们贫穷的亲戚。他们做得不太好，所以他们决定去别的地方。
The move started a tradition. Each successive generation went to wherever the next big thing was, first to Vermont for a better farm, then to Ohio for steel, Wall Street for finance, and eventually, Texas for oil. And it only took a little bit of wealth to make everything a lot easier.
这次搬迁开创了一个传统。每一代人都去下一个大事件发生的地方，先是去佛蒙特州寻找更好的农场，然后去俄亥俄州从事钢铁业，去华尔街从事金融，最终，去德克萨斯州寻找石油。只需要一点财富就能让一切变得容易得多。
You see, they use the prep schools. They use Yale. They use the whole summer connection to meet wives, which means a kind of use of the social register world. And they instill senses of duty and sportsmanship and fair play, but they also introduce this issue, call it sense of entitlement, which many people have labeled smugness in the candidates or whatever. And they've now been in the forefront of American politics for about three generations.
你看，他们利用预科学校。他们利用耶鲁。他们利用整个暑假联系来结识妻子，这意味着某种对社会名流世界的利用。他们灌输责任感、体育精神和公平竞争的意识，但他们也引入了这个议题，称之为权利感，许多人将这种权利感称为候选人的自负等等。他们现在已经在前沿美国政治中处于领先地位大约三代人了。
Each generation, starting in the 1800s, would make the family a little richer, a little more blue blood, and then would use their money and friends to create a network of political allies. And only once that network was in place do they run for office. All the Bushes do this.
从1800年代开始的每一代，都会让家族变得更富有、血统更纯正一点，然后利用他们的金钱和朋友建立一个政治盟友网络。只有当那个网络就位后，他们才会竞选公职。所有的布什家族成员都这样做。
Prescott Bush got richer than his dad on Wall Street, then made friends, then went to the Senate. George Herbert Walker Bush got even richer in Texas, then made even more friends, then became president. George W. hopes he'll do the exact same thing.
普雷斯科特·布什在华尔街赚得比他父亲多，然后结交朋友，然后进入参议院。乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布什在德克萨斯赚得更多，然后结交了更多的朋友，然后成为总统。乔治·W·希望他能做同样的事情。
All the while, my family stayed. And each generation, the family land got smaller. Their only friends were other farmers. So when things finally got bad enough that they had to leave, about 100 years ago, the only place to go was a blue collar job in the city. By then, our family went from being the Bushes' superiors to being nothing but Swamp Yankee trash, while our poor Bush cousins stopped having to work so hard.
一直以来，我的家人留了下来。每一代，家庭土地都变得更小。他们唯一的朋友是其他农民。所以当事情最终变得糟糕到他们必须离开时，大约100年前，唯一能去的地方就是城市里的蓝领工作。到那时，我们的家庭从布什家族的优等生变成了除了“沼泽扬基”垃圾之外什么都不是，而我们贫穷的布什堂亲却不再需要那么努力工作了。
Now, what makes the Bushes interesting is that they have, like all dynastic families, a mythology, and a set of traditions and values that they pass on from one generation to the next.
现在，布什家族有趣的地方在于，像所有王朝家族一样，他们有一套神话，以及从一代传到下一代的一套传统和价值观。
This is Adam Bellow. He's writing a book about nepotism. His father is Saul Bellow, winner of the Nobel Prize for Literature.
这是亚当·贝娄。他正在写一本关于任人唯亲的书。他的父亲是诺贝尔文学奖获得者索尔·贝娄。
And in the Bush family, it's considered important to be, or to appear to be, a self-made man. Therefore, the younger Bush, George Senior, George Herbert Walker Bush, likes to tell the story that he, after graduating from Yale, got into his car with his wife and his infant son, George Junior, and drove off to Texas to get into the oil business. He doesn't mention that he used his father's connections to start an oil company. And the same thing is true, of course, of his son, George Junior, and Jeb Bush.
在布什家族，被认为或表现为一个白手起家的人是很重要的。因此，年轻的布什，乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布什，喜欢讲述这样一个故事：他在耶鲁毕业后，带着妻子和襁褓中的儿子乔治·小布什，开车前往德克萨斯州投身石油行业。他没提他利用父亲的关系创办了一家石油公司。当然，他的儿子乔治·小布什和杰布·布什也是如此。
Not that Adam Bellow thinks there's anything wrong with that. Nepotism is not good. It's not bad. It's how the world works. Only in America does anyone get upset about this, anyway. Because ever since Benjamin Franklin filled his Poor Richard's Almanac with advice on how to be prosperous, there's been this idea that anyone can make it here with pluck and hard work.
并不是亚当·贝娄认为这有什么问题。任人唯亲并不好，也不坏。这就是世界的运作方式。反正只有在美国，人们才会对此感到不安。因为自从本杰明·富兰克林用关于如何致富的建议填满了他的《穷理查年鉴》以来，就一直有这样一种观点：任何人都可以在这里凭借毅力和勤奋获得成功。
Franklin was a man of the middle class.
富兰克林是一个中产阶级的人。
A self-made man.
一个白手起家的人。
A self-made man. And interestingly, when he became Postmaster General of the colonies, in the 1730s, he gave all the jobs that he had under his control, in all the 13 colonies, to his relatives. All the postmasters in all the colonies were nephews and cousins and relatives of Ben Franklin, and he moved them around at will. And when one of them died, he would give the job to another relative. And this is the great self-made man of American history.
一个白手起家的人。有趣的是，当他在1730年代成为殖民地邮政总长时，他把他控制下的所有工作，在所有13个殖民地，都给了他的亲戚。所有殖民地的邮政局长都是本·富兰克林的侄子、堂兄弟和亲戚，他随意调动他们。当其中一个人去世时，他会把工作交给另一个亲戚。这就是美国历史上伟大的白手起家者。
It sounds like what you're saying is not only do the wealthy know how to use it better and have more raw material with which to work, but they also are the only part of our society that doesn't have a stigma against it, or at least is very happy to overcome that stigma. And so I wonder if it would be good for us to open up America to nepotism, to say here today, everybody use it, use it all you can, and let's make this a major tool in getting everybody the best advantage they can.
听起来你是说，富有的人不仅知道如何更好地利用它，拥有更多可利用的原始资料，而且他们也是我们社会中唯一没有对此感到耻辱的部分，或者至少非常乐于克服那种耻辱。所以我不知道向任人唯亲开放美国是否对我们有好处，可以说，从今天起，每个人都使用它，尽可能多地使用它，让我们把它作为让每个人获得最佳优势的主要工具。
Where I come down on this is that it's never going away. Studies of the labor market, that is, how people get jobs, indicate that most people continue to get jobs through their relatives. It is just the way things are done.
我在这个问题上的结论是，它永远不会消失。对劳动力市场的研究，即人们如何获得工作，表明大多数人继续通过亲戚获得工作。事情就是这样做的。
Adam Bellow has been studying nepotism for years. And he hasn't found any level of society, anywhere in the world, that doesn't use it. So how do you feel good about yourself when you're sitting there in that nice office that you didn't really earn? Well for one thing, says Adam Bellow, you can have some humility about how you got the job. And you can work your ass off. You can work so hard that you earn the privilege that you lucked into.
亚当·贝娄研究任人唯亲多年。他没有发现社会中任何级别、世界上任何地方不使用它的。那么，当你坐在那个你并没有真正赢来的漂亮办公室里时，你怎么感觉良好呢？嗯，首先，亚当·贝娄说，你可以对你是如何得到这份工作的保持谦逊。你可以努力工作。你可以努力工作到为你偶然获得的特权赚得理直气壮。
Take the two George Bushes. Elizabeth Mitchell, who wrote W: the Revenge of the Bush Dynasty, told me that they both say they are self-made men. And they're both obviously fooling themselves. Their families gave them tremendous head starts.
拿两位乔治·布什来说。写了《W：布什王朝的复仇》的伊丽莎白·米切尔告诉我，他们都说自己是白手起家的人。他们显然都在自欺欺人。他们的家族给了他们巨大的领先优势。
When George Herbert Walker Bush, the father, the former president, moved to Odessa, Texas, and worked the lowest jobs at an oil company, painting rigs and handling supplies, the company he worked for was Dresser Industries. It was owned by his father's best friend and Yale roommate, Neil Mallon. In fact, Senator Prescott Bush gave the company to Mallon to run.
当身为前总统的父亲乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布什搬到德克萨斯州奥德萨，在一家石油公司从事最低层工作，粉刷钻机和处理物资时，他工作的公司是Dresser Industries。它是由他父亲最好的朋友和耶鲁室友尼尔·马隆拥有的。事实上，参议员普雷斯科特·布什把公司交给了马隆经营。
George Senior worked hard, and he ultimately started his own business. He was actually kind of brilliant. He was a pioneer in offshore drilling. When he became rich, richer than his dad, he earned it.
老布什努力工作，他最终创立了自己的事业。他实际上有点天才。他是海上钻探的先驱。当他变得富有，比他父亲还富有的时候，他是靠自己的努力。
Now take his son. When George W. drove to Midland, Texas, right after graduating from Yale, he went straight to his father's best friend, his father's former campaign manager, Jimmy Allison, who set him up in a low-level oil industry job. That went nowhere. Then he ran for Congress, lost, and then started a huge oil company himself.
现在拿他的儿子来说。当乔治·W在从耶鲁毕业后立即开车前往德克萨斯州米德兰时，他直接去了他父亲最好的朋友，也就是他父亲的前竞选经理吉米·艾里森那里，艾里森为他在石油工业谋得了一个低层工作。那没有进展。然后他竞选国会议员，失败了，然后自己创办了一家大型石油公司。
He didn't start at the bottom. He just called his uncle, Jonathan Bush, who quickly raised the money to create Arbusto. The primary funder was Philip Uzielli, James Baker's best friend and college roommate, a man who said he knew he probably wouldn't make any money, but felt loyal to W's dad. Sure enough, Arbusto went belly-up.
他并没有从底层开始。他只是打电话给他叔叔乔纳森·布什，乔纳森迅速筹集资金创建了Arbusto公司。主要出资人是詹姆斯·贝克最好的朋友和大学室友菲利普·乌齐耶利，一个人说他知道自己可能赚不到钱，但对W的父亲感到忠诚。果不其然，Arbusto公司破产了。
George W. went on to get family friends to buy him two other oil companies that also went bankrupt. He didn't have any money, no successes to be proud of. And that is when his dad's pal, Bill DeWitt, invited him to become a co-owner and the CEO of the Texas Rangers. George W. had to borrow money to buy in, because he was broke.
乔治·W随后让家族朋友买下了他也破产的其他两家石油公司。他没钱，没有任何值得骄傲的成功。那是他父亲的朋友比尔·德威特邀请他成为德州游骑兵队的共同所有者和首席执行官的时候。乔治·W不得不借钱买入，因为他破产了。
People say he did do a good job with the Rangers. He got taxpayers to give $135 million for a new stadium. And he finally made himself and his dad's friends some money.
人们说他确实在游骑兵队做得不错。他让纳税人支付了1.35亿美元用于修建一个新体育场。他最终为自己和他父亲的朋友们赚了一些钱。
In tracing the Bush family tree, I found that every single generation since 1780 has found new ways to make money and gain power. They were visionaries. They figured out what the next big thing would be, and then they took risks and reaped the rewards. And my family didn't.
在追踪布什家谱时，我发现自1780年以来的每一代人都找到了赚钱和获取权力的新方法。他们是有远见的人。他们搞清楚了下一个大事件是什么，然后他们承担风险并获得了回报。而我的家人没有。
Bush's family has been working towards this Tuesday's election carefully and steadily for the last 220 years, while we Swamp Yankees have been watching it on TV. And at some level, it doesn't seem unfair. The only thing that bothers me is that they're sending in George W. to take the big prize.
布什家族在过去220年里一直小心翼翼、稳步地为这个周二的选举做准备，而我们“沼泽扬基人”一直是在电视上观看。某种程度上，这似乎并不公平。唯一困扰我的是他们派乔治·W去赢取大奖。
He hasn't been a visionary or a risk-taker. If he'd followed the family tradition, he'd have gone to Silicon Valley and started a dot com. Instead, he entered the west Texas oil business when it was on its way out, and was bailed out repeatedly by family and friends. And he could be our next president. Or we'll get the other guy, the son of the senator from Tennessee.
他既不是远见卓识者，也不是冒险家。如果他遵循家族传统，他本会去硅谷创办一家互联网公司。相反，他在西德克萨斯石油工业走下坡路时进入该行业，并反复得到家人和朋友的救助。他可能成为我们的下一任总统。或者我们将得到另一个人，来自田纳西州的参议员的儿子。
Adam Davidson lives in Los Angeles.
亚当·戴维森住在洛杉矶。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Blue Chevigny and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, [? Eric Haverston, ?] and the amazing Hillary Frank. Musical help from Mr. John Connors, also Marika Partridge and Terry Hecker.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作，还有蓝色切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特经营我们的网站。来自托德·巴赫曼、[埃里克·哈弗斯顿]和了不起的希拉里·弗兰克的制作协助。来自约翰·康纳斯先生的音乐协助，还有玛丽卡·帕特里奇和特里·赫克。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持]
WBEZ management by Torey Malatia, who believes above all in sharing.
WBEZ管理由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他首先相信分享。
Here's your pen back. No, you can't have my pen back.
这是你的笔，还给你。不，你不能要回我的笔。
I'm Ira Glass. Don't forget to vote. God bless you, and God bless America.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。别忘了投票。上帝保佑你，上帝保佑美国。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。